well I've had a job higher up on the
organization chart I was offered more so
I did start with a higher salary there
is a clear separation between our
non-certified and certified
my name's Ramon Gonzalez I am a senior
project manager for one of the largest
Credit Union in Houston Texas my
background comes from a financial
industry I've always been in the fintech
world I worked as an operations director
of operations for a fintech company it
was in 2014 that this organization was
sold so we decided that we were going to
venture out on our own and start our own
engine it started off pretty rough or
difficult we encountered a lot of
obstacles prone but we were very
fortunate in about 18 to 20 months we
have grown to around 300 employees and
we were present in five different
countries and that was throughout a
little under three years when we decided
to sell and I came to a bathroom which I
decided you know what I need to start
contrasting from Smash so I'm good at
taking somebody's business requirement
and developing it which ultimately
defines about a project manager is and
around 2017 early 2018 is when I said
you know what let's
hope down that aisle
[Music]
in order to compete you need to stand up
and there is a lot of people
non-certified of people out there that
have a lot more experience to than I do
the only way that I can stand out is
getting my certification when I started
doing my research part of my research is
feedback reviews what other people I I
was working I needed something that
could really fit in my schedule with
that in mind I look for reviews I look
for people's feedback who have done that
already and simply learned just a spot
[Music]
I think that the certification gave me
the courage to stand out to say all
right I'm certified I took it I passed
on my first try within 85 so I will be
very honest I thought that I was not
going to pass but um I remember that
that morning take finishing the test and
hearing that I'm passing I'm like what
this wow great
well I've had a job higher up on the
organizational chart I was suffered more
so I did start with a higher salary I am
tired I am in pm2 instead of pm1 because
my certification
the other two PMS uh that are pm2 is
they they have that number because of
their
um longevity in the company I think
they've been with a company 19 years and
then the other one has been with the
organization 30 years there is a clear
separation between our non-certified and
certified
[Music]
I think for a project manager uh in my
position next steps would be having a
program manager maybe a director of pmo
so I'm really striving for that
foreign